en la mayoría de los temas hay que
avanzar bastante antes de entrar a la
parte filosófica e interesante del mismo
pero en química comenzamos desde el
inicio con lo que podemos decir es la
parte filosófica más interesante de todo
el tema y esa es el átomo la idea del
átomo como lo imaginaban los filósofos
de la antigüedad y ustedes pueden buscar
a los diferentes filósofos que
reflexionaron primero al respecto ellos
decían que si comenzábamos a cortar algo
no se una manzana y seguíamos cortando
esta manzana de esta manzanita rica y la
vamos a ir cortando en pedazos cada vez
más pequeños hasta que eventualmente
llegamos a un pedazo tan pequeño que ya
no podemos cortarlo más y estoy segura
de que muchos de estos filósofos tomaron
sus cuchillos y trataron de hacerlo y
seguro pensaron que quizás si tuvieran
un cuchillo más filoso podrían seguir
cortando así que es una construcción
totalmente filosófica la cual
francamente en muchos sentidos no es
demasiado diferente de cómo conocemos al
átomo él
es en realidad una abstracción mental
que nos permite describir mucho de las
observaciones que vemos en el universo
pero de cierta manera esos filósofos
decían que en algún momento llegaríamos
a la parte tan pequeña de la manzana que
ya no podríamos cortar o dividirla más y
a esto le llamaron átomo y esto no sólo
se aplica para las manzanas decían ellos
esto se cumplía para cualquier sustancia
o cualquier elemento que encontrábamos
en el universo y por eso usamos la
palabra átomo que viene del griego
indivisible aunque ahora sabemos que el
átomo sí puede dividirse aún cuando no
es algo trivial hacerlo no es la parte
más pequeña que conocemos de la materia
ahora sabemos que el átomo está
compuesto de otras partículas
fundamentales y permítanme escribirlas
así que tenemos al neutrón y en un
momento escribiré cómo todas forman
parte de la estructura del átomo el
protón y tenemos electrones y es posible
que ya estén familiarizados con esto si
es que han visto viejos vídeos de
proyectos atómicos verán
que se ve algo así voy a tratar de
dibujar uno tendrán esto en el centro y
estas cosas dando vueltas alrededor más
o menos así
que tienen órbitas que se ven así la
emoción general detrás de este tipo de
dibujos nucleares y estoy segura que
todavía se ven en algún laboratorio de
defensa o algo así es que tenemos en el
centro el núcleo del átomo y sabemos que
el núcleo tiene neutrones y protones y
veremos con más detalle sobre cuantos
neutrones y protones tienen los
diferentes elementos y alrededor aquí
usaré la palabra
órbita aunque en dos minutos veremos que
esta palabra es incorrecta incluso la
imagen mental que nos da no refleja la
realidad de lo que hace un electrón pero
la idea antigua era que teníamos estos
electrones que giran en órbita alrededor
del núcleo de manera similar a como la
tierra y los planetas giran alrededor
del sol aunque se ha demostrado que eso
no es lo que sucede realmente en el
átomo cuando veamos mecánica cuántica
aprenderemos por qué esto no funciona
así y cuáles son las contradicciones que
surgen cuando se trata de modelar un
electrón como un planeta girando
alrededor del sol pero este es más o
menos la idea original y francamente
pienso que es
es la forma más popular de imaginar un
átomo yo mencioné que el átomo era
interesante filosóficamente porque pues
porque la forma actual que tenemos de
ver al átomo comienza a desdibujar la
línea entre nuestra realidad física y
todo lo que hay en el mundo que es en
realidad información en realidad no
existe algo así como materia pura o
partículas puras de la manera en que las
definimos en nuestra vida cotidiana para
mí una partícula es como un granito de
arena lo puedo tomar y tocar mientras
que una onda podría ser como el sonido
puede ser como un cambio de energía en
el tiempo pero aprenderemos
especialmente cuando veamos mecánica
cuántica que todo esto se confunde
conforme nos acercamos a la escala del
tamaño de un átomo de cualquier manera
ya les había comentado que esa es una
manera incorrecta de imaginarse a el
átomo cuál es la manera correcta resulta
que esta imagen realmente no es una
imagen solo es una representación así
que una pregunta interesante es cómo
podemos obtener la imagen de un átomo
que la mayoría de las longitudes de onda
de luz son mucho más grandes que el
tamaño de un átomo y todo lo que
observamos en la vida es debido a la luz
reflejada pero de pronto cuando
trabajamos con un átomo la luz reflejada
es demasiado grande o demasiado tosca
como instrumento para observar a la toma
esta es una representación de un átomo
de helio un átomo de helio tiene dos
protones y dos neutrones o al menos este
átomo de helio tiene dos protones y dos
neutrones y la forma de representar el
núcleo aquí es que estos dos rojos yo
supongo que son los protones y los
púrpuras son neutrones a mí me parece
que el púrpura es un color neutro y
estos se encuentran en el centro de este
átomo y esta cosa borrosa alrededor son
los dos electrones que tiene el átomo de
helio quizás se puede ganar o perder un
electrón pero estos son dos electrones y
ustedes me pueden decir oye cómo que
esta cosa borrosa pueden ser dos
electrones esto parece que está
embarrado alrededor del átomo y es aquí
donde se comienza a poner
filosóficamente interesantes
no se puede describir la ruta del
electrón alrededor del núcleo con la
idea tradicional de la órbita como la de
los planetas alrededor del sol resulta
que con un electrón no se puede conocer
su momento y su ubicación al mismo
tiempo solo podemos conocer la
distribución de probabilidad de en donde
podría estar y la forma de representar
esto es este borrón que es más oscuro en
donde es más probable que se encuentre
el electrón y más claro donde es menos
probable que aparezca pero realmente el
electrón podría estar en cualquier lugar
o estar aquí donde está completamente
blanco que es un lugar con una
probabilidad realmente baja así pues
esta función en donde podría encontrarse
un electrón se le llama orbital orbital
no confundir con órbita recuerden que
una órbita es algo así como venus
alrededor del sol y eso es algo que nos
resulta muy fácil de imaginar pero un
orbital es en realidad una función de
probabilidad matemática que nos dice
dónde es más probable que encontremos un
electrón
más al respecto cuando veamos mecánica
cuántica aunque esto no será durante
estos vídeos introductorios se química
sin embargo es muy interesante verdad el
comportamiento de un electrón es tan
bizarro tan extraño a esta escala que
llamarlo incluso partícula es erróneo se
le llama partícula pero no es una
partícula en el sentido que le damos en
la vida cotidiana es una cosa que ni
siquiera podemos decir en donde está
podría estar en cualquier lado de esta
parte borrosa más adelante veremos que
estas zonas borrosas pueden tener formas
distintas
conforme agregamos más y más electrones
a un átomo para mí esto da pie a
problemas filosóficos de qué es la
materia o sobre cómo vemos las cosas y
cómo son en realidad o qué tan reales
son al menos con lo que nosotros
definimos como realidad bueno no quiero
ponerme demasiado filosófica con ustedes
pero toda la noción de electrones y
protones están relacionadas con la
noción de carga ya hemos hablado de esto
antes cuando aprendimos acerca de la ley
de colom pueden revisar los vídeos de la
ley de colom en la lista de vídeos de
física
es que un electrón tiene una carga
negativa un protón que a veces se
escribe así tiene una carga positiva y
un neutrón no tiene carga lo cual era
algo bastante tentador en el modelo
original de un electrón si decimos estas
son las cargas positivas digamos que dos
neutrones y dos protones como los que
tienen un átomo de ella tendremos cargas
positivas y aquí afuera tendremos
algunas cargas negativas las cargas
opuestos se atraen y si estas cosas
tienen algo de velocidad la suficiente
velocidad pues podrían orbitar alrededor
así como los planetas giran alrededor
del sol pero ahora sabemos que aunque
esto es parcialmente cierto que mientras
más lejano está el electrón del núcleo
este tendrá más energía potencial es
decir este querrá acercarse al núcleo
pero debido a la mecánica a nivel
cuántico éste no hará algo sencillo como
moverse en una ruta así como lo haría un
cometa alrededor del sol
eso tiene este comportamiento tipo 1
en donde se tiene esta función de
probabilidad que la describe pero
mientras más lejano esté el orbital este
tendrá más potencial veremos más al
respecto en futuros vídeos de todas
maneras cómo podemos saber de qué
elementos se trata he hablado mucho
sobre aspectos filosóficos pero como sé
que esto es helio es por el número de
neutrones que tiene por el número de
protones o por el número de electrones
la respuesta está en el número de
protones si conocemos el número de
protones en un elemento sabremos de qué
elementos se trata el número de protones
se define como el número atómico
digamos que algo tiene cuatro protones
como sabemos qué elemento es
si no lo hemos memorizado lo podemos
buscar en la tabla periódica de los
elementos la cual veremos mucho durante
esta serie de vídeos así que buscamos el
elemento con cuatro protones y vemos que
es el berilio justo acá este número
atómico que vemos aquí arriba es
literalmente el número de protones y
esto es lo que hace la diferencia entre
un átomo y otro si tenemos 15 protones
tendremos fósforo si tenemos 7 protones
tendremos nitrógeno si tenemos mucho
tendremos oxígeno esto es lo que define
a un elemento ahora veremos más adelante
qué sucede con la carga y todo eso o que
pasa cuando ganamos o perdemos
electrones pero eso no cambia el
elemento con el que estamos trabajando
esto nos lleva a una pregunta obvia
cuántos neutrones y electrones tenemos
si un átomo tiene carga neutra significa
que tiene el mismo número de electrones
digamos que tengo carbono cuyo número
atómico es 6 digamos que es un número de
masa atómica es 2
qué significa esto bueno estamos
diciendo que esta es una partícula
neutra un átomo neutro por lo tanto el
número atómico del carbono que es 6 nos
dice exactamente el número de protones
que tiene si yo fuera dibujar un modelo
aquí que para nada va a ser exacto le
dibujar y a 6 2 3 4 5 6 protones en el
centro y el peso de dichos protones
si cada protón es una unidad de masa
atómica oiea veremos que es una fracción
muy pequeña de un kilogramo
aproximadamente 1.6 por 10 a la menos 27
kilogramos el cual es un número muy muy
pequeño
de hecho es casi imposible de imaginar
al menos para mí esto me dice la masa de
todo un átomo completo de carbono de
este átomo de carbono en particular y de
hecho esto puede cambiar de átomo de
carbono a otro átomo de carbono y es
esencialmente la masa de todos los
protones más todos los neutrones cada
protón tiene una masa atómica de 1 en
unidades demás autómicas cada neutrón
tiene una
masa atómica unitaria así que esto es en
realidad el número de protones
y el número de neutrones
en este caso tenemos 6 protones por lo
que también debemos tener 6 neutrones
se es neutrales +6 protones nos da 12
y dónde están los electrones dijimos que
es neutro así que el protón tiene la
misma carga positiva que los electrones
tienen como carga negativa en este átomo
neutro tenemos 6 protones por lo que
también tendremos 6 electrones y
permíteme dibujar
dijimos que tiene 6 neutrones aquí en el
núcleo si fuéramos a dibujar electrones
podría dibujar un borrón aquí pero si
queremos visualizar lo mejor yo diría
que aquí tenemos 6 electrones alrededor
que se mueven de forma impredecible de
la manera que lo describe la función de
probabilidad lo interesante de esto es
que la mayor parte de la masa del átomo
se encuentra aquí quizás ya se dieron
cuenta de que el número de masa atómica
se refiere a la masa del núcleo del
átomo e ignora la masa de los electrones
esto se debe a que la masa de un protón
es igual a 1.836 electrones a la masa de
1836 electrones así que pensar en la
masa del átomo para propósitos prácticos
es pensar en la masa del núcleo
el átomo ahora ustedes pueden ver esta
tabla periódica aquí y decir bueno nos
dan el número atómico aquí arriba el
número atómico del oxígeno es 8
significa que tiene 8 protones el número
atómico del silicio es 14 tiene 14
protones y qué es esto de aquí arriba
veamos al carbono aquí tiene un 12
puntos 0 107 ese es el peso atómico del
carbono permítanme escribirlo peso
atómico
del carbono
es
12.00 107 qué significa esto significa
que el carbono tiene 6 protones y un
remanente y el remanente 6.010 7
neutrones acaso hay algún tipo de
fracción de neutrón no significa que si
promediamos todas las versiones
diferentes que hay del carbono en el
planeta si obtuvieron es el promedio del
número de neutrones basados en la
cantidad de los diferentes tipos de
carbono este es el número que
obtendríamos resulta que el carbono
tiene dos formas principales la más
común y la principal que encontraremos
es el carbono 12 6 protones y 6
neutrones y después tendremos otro
isótopo de carbono un isótopo es el
mismo elemento pero con diferente número
de neutrones otro isótopo de carbono es
carbono 14 el cual es mucho más escaso
en el planeta si promediamos estos y no
me refiero a un promedio directo pues
tendríamos carbono 13 el peso atómico
sería 13 pero si le damos mayor
al primero ya que existen mayor cantidad
de la tierra prácticamente el carbono 12
es casi todo el carbón que podemos
encontrar en el planeta pero hay otro
poquito de este otro carbono si los
promediar amos en relación a su
abundancia el promedio sería este así
que la mayor parte del carbono que
existe su peso promedio en unidad de
masa atómica serán 12 puntos 0 10 7 pero
la idea de un isótopo es interesante
recuerden que cuando cambiamos neutrones
no cambiamos el elemento fundamental se
obtiene una versión diferente del mismo
elemento un isótopo del mismo elemento
así que ambas versiones de isótopos son
carbonos quiero dejar el vídeo con lo
que pienso que es la idea más genial
detrás de los átomos y es la cosa
filosófica más interesante de estos en
este tamaño relativo tenemos a los
electrones que representan unas cosas
muy pequeñas de la masa del átomo 11
entre 2000 de la masa del átomo son
electrones e incluso es difícil
describir a los electrones como
partículas ya que no podemos saber
exactamente en dónde están
qué tan rápido se están moviendo solo
tienen esta función de probabilidad por
lo que la mayor parte del átomo se va a
encontrar en el núcleo y esto es lo
interesante si dijéramos que este es mi
átomo digamos que tengo dos átomos que
se encuentran unidos mutuamente si yo me
preguntara qué tanto de esto es materia
y cuando digo materia me refiero a un
concepto muy abstracto porque estamos
hablando del núcleo es cierto
debido a que el núcleo es donde se
encuentra toda la masa toda la materia
resulta que eso es una fracción
infinitesimal del volumen del átomo
incluso el volumen del átomo es difícil
de definir ya que el electrón puede
aparecer prácticamente en cualquier
parte pero si vemos el volumen como el
lugar en donde es más probable que
encontremos al electrón o donde tengamos
un 90% de probabilidad de encontrarlo
entonces el núcleo ocupa en la mayoría
de los casos un 1 entre 10.000 partes
del volumen si piensan en ello cuando
miran un objeto con sus manos o las
paredes oa su computadora el 99.99 por
ciento de ellos
espacio libre es nada es vacío si
tuvieran creo que podríamos llamar las
partículas o algo ultra pequeñas la
mayor parte de ellas a través serían las
cosas que podemos ver así que esto nos
lleva a pensar qué es lo que mantiene
nuestra realidad qué es lo que queda y
esto es un hecho no una teoría si vemos
los bloques básicos de cualquier cosa a
nivel atómico la mayoría de lo que hay
en el átomo es espacio libre y vacío
podríamos atravesarlo limpiamente si
pudiéramos reducirnos a esa escala esta
imagen de un átomo de helio aquí dice
que esto mide un centímetro
esta es la escala del núcleo del átomo
de helio cierto un centímetro y esto de
aquí es un armstrong y resulta que un
astro mide 100 mil ciento metros sólo
para darnos una idea de la escala una
acción es 1 por 10 a la menos 10 metros
así que un átomo mide aproximadamente un
astro en este caso el núcleo del helio
es una fracción aún
es pequeña una entre 100.000 partes así
que si tuviéramos digamos que helio
líquido el cual se obtiene enfriando
mucho el helio si lo observamos la
mayoría de esto sería espacio libre si
ven una barra de hierro la gran gran
gran mayoría de este es espacio libre y
ni siquiera estamos hablando de que tal
vez existe espacio libre dentro del
núcleo de eso hablaremos en el futuro
pero para mí eso hace que mi imaginación
explote ya que la mayoría de las partes
de las cosas que vemos no son en
realidad sólidas están compuestas de
espacio vacío pero lucen sólidas por la
forma en que la luz se refleja en ellas
o por las fuerzas que los repelen pero
realmente no hay nada que se pueda tocar
la mayoría de lo que existe en ese
espacio vacío y es aquí donde me despido
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo